[Music]
in a story sometimes it's the villains
who are the most tragic ones you see
they go to saying that a good villain
knows how to make you hate him but a
great villain is someone who has
justified actions and might as well be
the hero in some other story while the
saying can be applied to varying degrees
of success in anime i do think it does
stick mind you there are quite a few
unjustified villains that go the
extremes but there are also some who
feel quite sympathetic especially once
you get to know them better
being sympathetic or not is a subjective
topic so for today we won't be talking
about the most sympathetic villains
on today's list i'll be listing some of
the shonen villains that i personally
felt sorry for whether it be due to
their backstory what fates they meet or
just simply the circumstances that they
had over the course of the story this
isn't meant to be a villain redemption
video but i can't help but feel bad
about some of these guys also as this is
a video with heavy ties to villain
backstories and developments expect
spoilers but i'll try not to go into too
many details
starting off today's list is none other
than all kiyora
[Music]
here's a tragic villain to start things
off among the espadas okiyora has one of
my favorite character developments what
makes all kiara so effective in this
role is the fact that this tragedy
doesn't come from a backstory like a lot
of the aspardas he doesn't have the sad
background as say stark or anime haribel
however he more than makes up for it
with how his character gets unraveled
through the huiko mundo arc initially
presented as the emotionless one amongst
the espada his stay with orihime
eventually opens to us the emptiness
that he really feels i'm not sure how
sympathetic of a character all kia ora
can be when it comes to the typical
bleach viewer but his curiosity about
understanding human emotions and the
human heart make for a dramatic journey
to follow his fixation with ichigo and
orihime stem from that very real desire
to understand humans to comprehend the
power of emotions they held within and
just as he's on the road to redemption
that door gets promptly shut on him it's
just a perfect way to end what i feel is
one of the most hyped fights in that arc
up next it's a man sucking on a pacifier
wearing a bonnet diaper and big
[Music]
despite his sunglasses and his girl gang
who insists he's hard-boiled which i
assume is the reason why he's such a hit
with the ladies
it's impossible to take this big belly
man child seriously at first but it
turns out the story behind that
ridiculous outfit isn't just serious
it's seriously sad
senora pink's clownish appearance is a
tribute to his dead son one that he puts
on for his wife russian with their
relationship already strained by their
son's death russian leaves pink upon
finding out that he's a pirate and not a
banker as he claims to be she's then
involved in an accident and ends up in a
vegetative state a shattered pink visits
her in hospital every day one day on
impulse he puts on a baby bonnet to coax
a smile out of her to his great surprise
he succeeds and that's the beginning of
his transformation a man brave enough to
be ridiculed by all for the smallest
reward and the briefest moment of
happiness has our respect
is up next in our rogues gallery of
tragic shonen villains
curiosity kill the cat is what i'd use
to describe zeref's downfall in this
world there are some things that we're
not meant to know and zereth just had to
have the curiosity to deal with life
itself it led to a curse one that would
begin his downward spiral zero for me is
a character whose reputation precedes
the truth about him for most of the
series he's been billed as this super
villain the ultimate dark wizard who
would end the world something like that
so i was excited to see him finally
confront the heroes quite early on in
the series only to have my expectations
subverted heck if anything it was
aknologia who fits the bill of the evil
destroyer more as the story of fairy
tale unfolds there have since become a
death seeker looking for atonement in
his endless trudge across the world
various legends that tell of his evil
have indeed been born but beyond all
these scary tales lies a broken man i
mean seeing everyone you ever cared for
die will take a toll on anyone and that
includes one of the most powerful
wizards in the world
we move on from battle shonen to look at
isabella
what lies beyond that firm facade of a
strong woman one who hides a very
sinister knowledge underneath her warm
smile as one of the best caretakers of
the grace field house tragedy
lots of it let's see isabella started
out quite the optimist like a lot of
them one of the best mom candidates she
reached that goal with record-breaking
feats however it's not without pain and
suffering and on route to claiming the
title of being the youngest mother of
them all she's lost so much in her
struggle to survive her new role does
open her up to the whole demon farming
system that's plagued these houses but
as if the tragedy of the system she's
trapped in isn't enough she gets privy
to another gut-wrenching truth one of
the children she's raising up to be fed
is none other than her own son for most
of the first season of the promised
neverland you see isabella as the cold
unflinching war that the children can't
ever seem to overcome a powerful
adversary who's overcome everything
thrown at her even attempts at
usurpation from a fellow colleague but
the end of it all shocks us with a twist
that gives a completely new perspective
to her character the promise neverland
season one is truly one of the best
anime had to offer in its year
i think it's about time to take a half
time break if you've enjoyed what you've
seen so far don't hesitate to subscribe
we're trying to get to that one million
subscriber milestone and we just need a
little bit more of a push to finally hit
that mark
[Music]
we resume the list with marouane
honestly
[Music]
i think it's not an unpopular opinion
that meruem is one of the best shonen
villains there is he may not have the
grandiose charisma of some of the most
broken ones like aizen or mardara but in
terms of character writing and
development he's just on par with the
rest of hunter hunter in terms of
execution i won't say that he
single-handedly carried the kimura
antarc but he sure as hell played a
crucial role in the arc being as awesome
as it was i'm not gonna lie his batter
with natero is a thing of legend there's
a lot to say about meruem that can
become a character study altogether like
how he's such a great foil for gone
despite not interacting with him spoiler
for a future video there maybe
but the moment that i'd love to focus on
for the sake of this video is his moment
of death don't lie that final moment
with gomugi should have made you shed a
tear at least he came into the series by
making an impact as a detestable villain
but we eventually see those traces of
cruelty crumble through these
interactions with others over the course
of an arc by the time he dies he's
become one of the best characters in
shonen anime a very honorable one of
that like all kiara he has his most
touching moments right at death's
doorstep closing the doors on one of my
favorite anime villains of all time
next up is hitachi
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i expect this to be the most polarizing
character that i picked for this list
much has been said about hitachi or the
uchihas in general trust me for those of
you who weren't around back then the
discussion on itachi's actions were a
remarkable sight i'd say it's on par
with a lot of ship wars or political
discussions in terms of intensity so was
hitachi a tragic hero all along was his
role in the whole massacre completely
justified
personally
i'm leaning towards no but
i do think that what's come out of his
actions is nothing short of tragic and
it's through those effects that feel bad
for him while he may have done some
reprehensible things he's proved that
things aren't as black and white as they
typically presented heck his actions
drove a little edgy brother to a whole
path of revenge when the true story
would quickly shatter sasuke's very
purpose for pursuing revenge and he had
to carry that burden with him all
throughout his run in the show all while
engaging in confrontations against
sasuke and fighting for his life you
could say what you want but the amount
of emotional baggage hitachi had to
carry was pretty insane the revelation
of the truth and his final sacrifice
makes his fight against sasuke even more
dramatic
and it's quickly become one of my
favorites ever since it first aired
following itachi we have shigaraki
[Music]
now this is a backstory that can really
hurt people on a personal level there's
nothing more painful than having a
father who just can't have it in him to
support your dreams as a child that's
some emotional scars that you just don't
recover from which makes the whole
shigeraki thing even more of a tragedy
we could have had a hero with such an
overpowered ability if only he had the
proper emotional support that a child
desperately needed from a father but
alas it wasn't meant to be and watching
shigaraki's whole story unfold was
something that severely tugged at my
heartstrings more than sadness for the
poor aspiring hero there was the sense
of frustration a sense of anger at the
father who was the reason for the child
to grow into the diabolical shigeraki
that we all know today in the name of
anger and bitterness at the world
shigaraki has done a lot of unforgivable
deeds what do you think about it can you
blame him for the path to villainy well
it's the bad guys who managed to show
the most empathy and understanding
towards him
attack on titan is about to wrap up and
it's about time that we paid more
tribute to it to close this list
[Music]
a textbook example of sanity slippage in
attack on titan we all know him for the
big reveal he made to aaron but by that
time he'd already gone off way into the
deep end it's the journey that i really
want to focus on here and it's on a road
filled with nothing but sorrow the once
idealistic kid would find all of that
crushed under the pressures of life it's
a long story to get where he is now but
i had nothing but sympathy for what he
had to go through in his youth and as
the main story starts rolling
who knew that all the while he'd been
hiding everything to exude a reliable
big brother image to his supposed
friends personally speaking i can
imagine a few things that could be as
emotionally taxing as that a traitor who
has all idealism sapped out of him and
to put on a front as one of the most
trustworthy characters that these young
bloods can ask for it's just spectacular
i'm sure that amongst the notable
characters in attack on titan reiner
would not be topping a list of people's
favorite or best character lists there
are just so many candidates to compete
with each with their own stories of
triumph and despair to tell however i
think that among those i find reina one
of the most tragic ones out there
and that wraps up my list of villains
that you just can't help but feel bad
about i hope you had fun going through
this list and if you ever had some
strong feelings regarding any of these
people i'd love to hear what you have to
say about it while you're at it don't
forget to check out the rest of the
channel for mostly countdown videos
memberships will also unlock some extra
videos that you could be interested in
so do consider that option you can also
connect with me on social media through
both instagram and patreon and both are
linked in the description box now i had
a really fun time making this list and i
would be extremely glad if you found it
to be an impressive list too until next
time